assembly a low-level programming
language designed to simplify the
instructions fed into a computer's cpu
in other words it's a human-readable
abstraction on top of machine code so
programmers don't have to manually count
ones and zeroes the first assembly
language was created by kathleen booth
in 1947 for the all-purpose electronic
computer over the next decade it evolved
into many different formats to power the
super computers of the day like the ibm
7090 which had a 20 million dollar price
tag in today's dollars writing code and
assembly was standard until the
emergence of high level languages like
fortran a few years later however
assembly is still used today for direct
access to the bare metal hardware and to
address low-level performance issues
often on device drivers and embedded
systems and it's also used to run native
software in a web browser via
webassembly what's tricky is that each
assembly language only works on a
specific cpu architecture like arm for
apple silicon and raspberry pi or x86
for intel chips to get started you'll
first need an assembler like the net
wide assembler for x86 chips an assembly
program is divided into three sections
the text section contains the actual
logic for the program by convention it
contains an entry point called start
which is where the code will start
executing next we have the block
starting symbol section which contains
variables that might change throughout
the lifecycle of the app and finally the
data section is where we can initialize
constants or data that does not change
to declare a constant like a string we
start with a label then use db for
defined byte to place the hello world
string into memory by itself it doesn't
do anything and to print it to the
standard output we will also need it to
length we can use equate to convert a
symbol into a constant the dollar sign
will subtract the current position from
the hello label providing the length of
the string and now these constants can
be referenced from the start label in
the main program each line of code
contains an instruction along with one
or more operands and there are hundreds
of instructions built into the language
now to perform operations quickly the
cpu has a limited number of registers
which are like 64-bit chunks of memory
built directly into the cpu instead of
the ram we can insert data into a
register with the move instruction by
providing operands for the register name
and the data to store there in this case
number one is used because it
corresponds to system write on linux
next we need to tell the system where to
write in which case we'll move one into
the rdi register which corresponds to
the standard output in the terminal the
next register stores the message to
right along with its length now execute
the code stored in the cpu by calling
the operating system kernel almost done
but we'll get a segmentation fault if we
try to run it at this point update the
racks register with 60 for system exit
and provide an error code of zero for a
success now use the assembler to compile
or assemble your code into an object
file then use the linker to convert it
into the final executable this has been
assembly language in 100 seconds if you
want to see more short videos like this
hit the like button and subscribe thanks
for watching and i will see you in the
next one